thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the microcosmos
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description can get a free trial
of skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
mermaids are apparently not real but
depending on how loose you are with your
definitions of fantastical creatures we
could be convinced that rotifers are
a little like microscopic mermaids yeah
they don't have any particularly human
resemblance but like sailors of old
might have confused sea creatures that
they saw with the fantastical creatures
in their heads
there's something kind of fun about
imagining the rotifer
as our own little mermaids but rotifers
do have something that the famous little
mermaid didn't have
and so desperately wanted ah what's the
word
oh right a foot it's that long thing
on the end which on any other animal we
might call a tail
or on a mermaid a fin and at the end of
the foot
is a toe through which the rotifer
produces a cement-like substance
so that it can glue itself to other
surfaces
of course the foot of a rotifer is not
actually a foot in the way that we think
about
feet nor is the toe a toe in the way we
think about
toes but it's hard not to peer into the
micro cosmos and
see the structure of things familiar
even if not exactly
the same take for example
the ciliate as we have seen often
throughout our journey to the
microcosmos
ciliates may just be composed of one
cell but they can put that one cell to
great use taking on many shapes and
forms that act
in magnificent ways the defining feature
of ciliates are the hairy cilia that
covers them
for some that's a general fuzziness that
covers their whole unicellular body but
for other ciliates
those cilia bundle together to form a
structure
called seri
with all those hairs working together
the seri
is more like a limb that helps the
organism move around
the effect for some species is that the
ciliate looks
almost like a weird misshapen centipede
as it creeps along the slide
of course there are organisms whose legs
and feet
are actual limbs like our favorite
tardigrades
whose bumbling bodies include four pairs
of legs
three along the trunk and another right
towards the butt end of the tardigrade
at the end of those legs are claws and
that means that yes depending on the
angle sometimes it looks like
tardigrades do have little butt claws
[Music]
oh and what a variety of claws they have
describing just one singular shape of
clause for tardigrades would be tough
because there are just so many different
ones out there
so much so that claws are one of the
features used to distinguish between
different species
whether that's by assessing the size of
them the number of them
or how they are attached to the
tardigrade's legs
because tardigrades live in many
different environments whether that's
water or moss or soil their legs and
claws are adapted to suit their home
those that live in soil tend to have
shorter legs and shorter claws than
those living in fresh water or on mosses
possibly to help them fit better in the
small spaces
available underground and some
tardigrades
have lost those hind claws entirely
which sounds a bit sad because just
think how cool it would be to have
butt claws but that's a small price to
pay for comfort and
survival
feet and legs have a purpose they help
organisms
move around but feet can also play a
different role altogether
if we switch up the scale we're looking
at
they can serve as a home if you've ever
gotten a whiff of
a smelly foot well you're probably
smelling the leavings of
bacteria you'll notice this particularly
when you've been wearing shoes that
aren't well ventilated
which makes your feet sweaty and
converts them into a nutritious
watery world for microbes as the
microbes metabolize the nutrients that
your
feet have expelled the bacteria produce
compounds that
just aren't that great to sniff
and then of course there are the more
nefarious means of
foot life this is a might
and it is beautiful in that creepy
unsettling way when it
is still but watching it crawl across
the screen kinda
makes it cute well cute until you
remember that there are species of mites
like the scabies might
that use their front legs to dig into
the outer layer of your skin
and lay their eggs and yes that includes
the skin
of people's feet mites aren't the only
parasite that finds their way into a
host through feet
if you want to continue to be unsettled
you can look into parasitic worms that
have taken advantage of
the proximity of feet to find their way
into
human bodies
now we could end on that unsettling note
but
instead let us revisit our microscopic
mermaids from the beginning of the
episode
the rotifer as we said the rotifer
technically has a foot but it's not
actually a foot
in some ways it's kind of the opposite
of a foot it keeps the rotifer anchored
to one place instead of helping it move
around
but rotifers are also happy to take
advantage
of other animals feed for transportation
a few years ago
a group of scientists obtained some
ducks feet from a local butcher
and then pressed them into samples of
sediment to see how well they could be a
vector
for rotifer dispersal well it turns out
they can though they're probably not
as effective at spreading rotifers
around the world
as something much more simple and less
animate
the wind
there are many of these invisible
mechanisms for transporting microbes
around the world
whether that is through the feet that
trod on the ground or fly through the
air
if you look up in the sky what you're
seeing there may be a bird
or invisibly it may be a rotifer
with its foot attached to a foot
attached
to some wings
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
if you'd like to add some additional
microbes to your feet you can get a pair
of paramecium socks
over at dftba.com and we'd also like to
say thank you again to skillshare for
supporting this video
even if you've already picked up a pair
of your paramecium socks you know one
pair of socks is never enough and with
skillshare
you can learn how to make your own among
the many
many helpful courses you can find on
skillshare there is
cozy house socks on introduction to sock
knitting
hosted by whitney hayward where you will
learn how to
take your knitting game to the next
level by making a pair of cozy
thick socks to keep your toes warm
around the house skillshare
is an online learning community that
offers membership with meaning
with so much to explore real world
projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth it's curated specifically
for learning meaning there are no ads to
distract you
and they are always launching new
premium classes so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your creativity
takes you and an annual premium
subscription to skillshare is less than
ten dollars a month
if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
the people who are on the screen right
now that's a bunch of names
and those people are the reason that we
can make weird videos
about microbes and feet we are very
happy to be able to do it
it is one of the joys of our life and
you are the reason
that that's possible if you'd like to
help us reach more people
and find more cool things in the micro
cosmos you can support this
show at patreon.com journey to micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button
somewhere nearby
you